es ist der skandal im deutschen
fernsehen rtl schmeißt janina josef
jahren aus dem dschungelcamp weil sie
kandidaten und mitstreiterinnen lindern
obert rassistisch beleidigt hat ja man
muss das ganz ehrlich sagen dieser
streit in dem diese vorwürfe oder diese
beleidigungen gefallen sind dagegen
eigentlich um etwas völlig banal es um
zwar und zwar um eine missglückte
dschungelprüfung am ende ist dieser dann
vollends eskaliert
mit du bist du ein team ja ich habe
daraus was gegen hass und liebe
gehört heißt einmal als ich halte meinen
mund nicht dazu da um zuspruch ist
geisteskrank und machen therapie wenn du
hier raus will du hast gut auf was aus
deinen dreckigen und bekommt nur scheiße
raus nur scheisse scheisse einfach
bescheid jetzt kapiert dass ich nicht
diejenige bin mit der du dich anlegen
wollten und stell dir das sagen was
du bist nicht noch mal in ein paar nicht
ach du wirst du mal bitte jedoch im
busch wiederholung busch wieder hugo
race ist dass solche aussagen sind
scheiße jedoch im busch wieder du
befindest dich gerade auf seinem
territorium in buer spezies
kommentar mit buschkow zurück ich nicht
zeigen
bernina entschuldige die für das wort
soll im buch das ist das ist ganz ganz
ganz
toll bild
opfer
das alles ist
ja eine entschuldigung gab es dann
stunden später
es tut mir wirklich sehr leid wenn das
rassistisch gäste rübergekommen ist
es tut mir wirklich leid ich hoffe du
kannst meine entschuldigung annehmen
herbst auf jeden fall
nimmst du meine entschuldigung an
ganz ehrlich janina tut mir wirklich
leid aber nein
geh doch zurück in den busch r worte die
unverzeihlich sind und wegen den janina
josef jahren aus dem dschungelcamp
geflogen ist bei mir ist heute im bild
buschfunk sagt mawick sarah du warst
2011 dschungel wenn du dieses sehen sie
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich war
gestern schockiert auch ein bisschen
fassungslos janina ist selbst erst mit
15 aus lehrern nach hamburg gekommen hat
migrations wurzeln so etwas aus ihrem
mund zu hören hat mich irgendwie
mitgenommen und ich habe nicht damit
gerechnet wie ging es dir also ich finde
diese bilder zu sehen absolut bedrückend
ich war total schockiert
ich habe mir die ganze haut gestern
aufgekratzt also allgemein die ganze
situation die hat die die ist einfach
ich habe das immer noch nicht verkraftet
was ich da gesehen habe und ich frag
mich muss sowas ausgestrahlt werden also
ich finde das alles so schlimm also
erstmal von gianina absolute
fehlverhalten
rassismus oder rassistische äußerungen
mobbing homophobie diese ganzen sachen
haben für mich im fernsehen nicht zu
suchen und dürfen eigentlich gar nicht
mehr ausgestrahlt werden wir dürfen den
ganzen sachen eigentlich gar keine
plattform geben
ich war überrascht ich kenne janina ich
war überrascht über ihre äußerung weil
in all den jahren wo ich sie kenne hat
sie noch nie in irgendeiner form eine
rassistische äußerung getätigt ich würde
mich sofort davon distanzieren weil ich
das ganz ganz schlimm finde auch gerade
wenn man im fernsehen das hat man schon
eine gewisse vorbildfunktion und what
your language man sollte aufpassen was
man auch äußert und sagt was mich an der
sache verwundert ist sie hat ja selber
wie du sagst auch diesen
migrationshintergrund und hat auch
selber schon rassistische dinge erfahren
müssen in ihrem leben ich weiß auch dass
ihre mutter zum beispiel die spricht
noch nicht mal deutsch wirklich so und
das dass das passt alles dann überhaupt
nicht zusammen wir wollen uns mal einmal
ganz kurz ihre entschuldigung an naja
hat ja sich tatsächlich versucht zu
distanzieren ja hat jetzt ein statement
veröffentlicht das wollen wir uns jetzt
einmal genau anschauen und zwar hat sie
geschrieben dass sie hat sich natürlich
in erster linie entschuldigt hier haben
wir das statement ich möchte mich
öffentlich für meine äußerungen
entschuldigen es tut mir aufrichtig leid
dass ich im dschungelcamp so sprachlich
entgleist bin mein verhalten um eine
äußerung gegenüber sind nicht zu
entschuldigen trotzdem bin ich der
meinung dass jeder im leben eine zweite
chance verdient hat es gibt für mich
keinen schwarz weiß ich habe selbst
einen migrationshintergrund und möchte
noch mal ausdrücklich sagen dass ich
mich von rassismus distanziere und
diesen nicht toleriere ich habe selbst
schon selber rassismus erfahren müssen
und wie schmerzlich es ist es ist die
unterste form einer beleidigung ich kann
die situation nicht zurückdrehen worte
sind gesprochen wurden und beschimpfung
gefallen auch wenn du das muss nicht zum
fernsehen zu suchen hat oder in unserer
gesellschaft gehören genauso wenig
beleidigungen in so ein format ist wäre
richtig gewesen und beide rauszunehmen
ich akzeptiere die entscheidung von rtl
möchte mich ausdrücklich von rassismus
distanzieren wir müssen einmal ganz kurz
darüber sprechen wer hat sie natürlich
tut sie entschuldigt sich distanziert
sich schon mal wieder an der stelle ihre
teil wichtig dass total wichtig die
genau aber sie gibt auch ein bisschen
den schwarzen peter der linda zu und
sagt man hätte uns beide rausnehmen
müssen das hätte sie jetzt vielleicht
nicht von sich sagen sollen dass das
könnte ich jetzt zum beispiel als
aussenstehende person sagen ich fand es
auch unglücklich dass man allgemein muss
man sich so artikulieren
man kann sich doch aus dem weg gehen um
was ich noch erschreckender finde ja was
ich habe diese szene gestern gesehen und
dann liegen die camper da alle im bett
gucken zu bevor das dann noch es wird ja
immer schlimmer und schlimmer wieso ist
keiner eingeschritten und hat gesagt du
in die eine ecke und du in die andere
ecke und jetzt ist hier schicht im
schacht oder mal in der aussprache alle
haben sich vor dem dschungel so da drin
dargestellt ja ich bin der teamplayer
und ich bin der streitschlichter und der
gute oder so aber keiner hat er mal
irgendwie mal eingegriffen das hätte ich
mir gewünscht von den anderen
teilnehmern gesagt so jetzt ist hier
feierabend in das heißt es ist die haben
es zugelassen dass es da drin so
eskaliert und nach meinem dschungelcamp
ja hätte und den linken mittlerweile
wirklich kennt jeder hätten die ein
bisschen schlauer sein können und alle
mal diese eskalation ein bisschen
unterbinden
bin ich einfach seit beide haben sich
also gerade sein ist das schlimmste
interessant ist die tatsache dass sie ja
zweimal diese äußerung getätigt hat und
nach der ersten äußerung kam erstmal gar
keine reaktion hat sich das noch mal
sagt dann hat linde gesagt du bist ein
races du bist dann kam er und navigation
also so das war so sie fingen damit an
und dann sind alle auf den zug
aufgesprungen und das finde ich ist ein
kleines armut also ich bin von dem ein
oder anderen darauf enttäuscht sie
hatten auch schon vorher wo die sich so
an gestichelt haben einfach mal ruhe
reinbringen sollen weil es wird doch
immer gesagt wir sind ein team wir sind
ein team muss das jetzt wieder so
aufkochen so was interessant war eure
reaktionen als dann verkündet wurde dass
janina das camp verlassen muss da gab es
nämlich schauen sie sich an jubelrufe
janina muss das camp verlassen
[Musik]
ich finde gut dass hier eine
entscheidung getroffen
danke
danke geklatsche
es ist ich finde dass nur noch
bedrückend ehrlich also ich finde das
nicht in ordnung und ich kann diese
aussagen nicht unterstützen ich finde
das nicht in ordnung dass sie sich da so
unglücklich geäußert hat es spricht
nicht für intelligenz sowas zu äußern
aber ich kann aus meiner erfahrung wie
ich sie kenne sagen dass sie noch nie in
irgendeiner form so eine äußerung
getätigt hat und ich also ich bin
richtig schockiert darüber aber man muss
auch sagen fairerweise die linda hat sie
auch so dermaßen die ganze zeit
gestichelt und in die ecke getrieben und
dann da ist dann ihr eine sicherung
durch gibt sicherung durch geplatzte ja
sogar aber es gibt eine keine
entschuldigung da sind wir uns auf eine
sind uns also wir uns auf ihr lassen
einmal nach südafrika schauen denn
unsere reporter sind in südafrika
unterwegs und wir wollen natürlich
wissen wie geht s janina josef jan und
was macht sie jetzt genau kannst du uns
dazu antworten liefern
janina josef hahn wurde ja nicht nur aus
dem dschungelcamp geworfen sondern
tatsächlich auch aus ihrem hotel da darf
sie nämlich jetzt auch nicht mehr sein
und dementsprechend wird sie jetzt heute
den rückflug antreten wir stehen hier
gerade schon am flughafen in höchst wo
sie jetzt gleich um die mittagszeit ja
zurück nach deutschland fliegen wird
kira weißt du wie es ihr geht konntest
du zb mit ihrer begleitperson sprechen
ja ich habe kontakt zu yvonne wilke das
ist eine freundin von gianina die jetzt
eben hier mit ihr zusammen diesen
dschungel camp trip gemacht hat und die
sie daneben begleitet hat hier ja nach
südafrika und die wollen und ich haben
uns heute morgen haben heute morgen
kontakt gehabt und sie hat auch noch mal
gesagt dass china wirklich am boden
zerstört ist sie versteht die welt nicht
mehr sie kann natürlich verstehen dass
viele leute sauer auf sie sind und sie
schämt sich auch für das was sie gesagt
hat aber sie sagt hat auch eben sie ist
eigentlich nicht so und sie hätte es
gerne eben gehabt dass ihre
entschuldigung angenommen werden würde
wie vonn hat mehr die morgen- bzw jetzt
gerade auch noch geschrieben und ich
lese es einmal vor gesagte worte kann
man nicht zurücknehmen auch wenn sie nie
so gemeint waren wie sie in der
situation gesagt wurden jeder kennt da
ist wenn man in einer diskussion immer
weiter auf den abgrund trinkt das einem
dann worte entfahren die einem sonst nie
entfahren würden wären ja sie haben auf
jeden fall wirklich das bereits gewonnen
und janina werden jetzt hier von hier
ausgleich dann nach deutschland
weiterfliegen danke da wir sind gespannt
was du später noch zu berichten hass und
wir wollen jetzt einmal direkt weiter
gehen zu john puthenpurackal
ebenfalls in südafrika ist und dort für
uns berichtet john erklär uns einmal wie
ist das mit diesem rauswurf genau
abgelaufen
ja der skandal ereignete sich ja wir das
auch schon beschrieben hat in der nacht
von sonntag auf montag
am montag hat dann hätte er ein in der
frühere entscheidung getroffen dass
janina musizieren das camp verlassen
muss sie wurde dann zu ihrer lodge in
der sie vor dem einzug in das camp
gewohnt hat in eskortiert und wurde dann
anschließend dann auch aus dem hotel
herausgebracht
jeder fragt sich was ist jetzt mit der
gage wir wissen es gibt sehr strikte
vertragliche regeln was passiert jetzt
bekommt die überhaupt noch kohle und wie
viel hätte die eigentlich bekommen
ja unserer information hätte sie eine
etage von rund 60.000 euro bekommen aber
nun nach diesem skandal nach der
kündigung des vertrags durch rtl wird
sie die gesamte summe definitiv nicht
bekommen das wird am ende sicherlich
auch ein wenig verhandlungssache sein
ihr würde aktuell rund 40 prozent der
gage zu stehen weil sie unterschrieben
hat und in das dschungelcamp eingezogen
ist doch ob sie nun wirklich diesen
betrag bekommt das müssen am ende
wahrscheinlich beide seiten aushandeln
bzw das wird sich rtl überlegen denn das
noch zu guter letzt die haben durch
diese art der kündigung nun die
möglichkeit die bisher zugesagte gage
zurückzufordern
vielen dank john aus südafrika und auch
du wirst uns auf dem laufenden halten
wenn es neuigkeiten gibt danke ich finde
das so bedrückend die ganze situation es
ist wirklich also für beide weil ich
denke auch hinter beiden steht auch eine
familie und alles nah man hat auch von
der linda die schwester gesehen dass das
finde ich manchmal so doof an reality tv
man steht da nicht als kunstfigur man
später als echter mensch und kann sich
sein ganzes leben durch so dumme sachen
einfach versauen aber man bekommt dafür
auch sehr viel geld und es gibt nur
rasen gewisse regeln an die man sich
nicht alles nur das stimmt es gibt
gewisse regeln an die man sich so weit
um die allerdings auch immer dagegen
verstößt da muss ein schöner weil ich
lerne hier wäre da muss schmerzlich
lernen bis so das leben ist ist das
leben des hart und mallorca kostet das
die camper auch ganz schön viel kohle
wie jetzt im fall von janina josef ihren
die möglicherweise auf einen großteil
wenn nicht sogar auf die ganze gage
verzichten muss das sind aber nicht die
einzelnen einzigen regeln die es im camp
gibt welche das sind und welche strafen
drohen das haben wir für sie mal
zusammen bekommt alles draußen
wo modell und 100.000 euro dieser
reichtum gebührt in diesem jahr
demjenigen der am ende der 16 tage auf
dem thron platz nimmt und dschungelkönig
2022 wird doch vorsicht promi sternchen
das geld kann schon vor der
inthronisation futsch sein denn wer sich
trash-tv unartig verhält muss tief in
die tasche greifen beginnen wir mit
einem waschechten dschungel schnäppchen
für die karte muss sein wer diese nicht
vor antritt im camp an der
hotelrezeption vorliegen kann muss 2000
euro in bar hinterlegen oder extra
kosten für den aufenthalt jenseits des
camps werden von der gage abgezogen
deswegen augen auf beim schampus kauf
teurer wird die flucht aus dem busch
lager 30.000 lassen kostet ist wenn ein
teilnehmer ohne ausdrückliche erlaubnis
das camp verlässt mitgehangen
mitgefangen
ebenfalls zur kasse werden
plaudertaschen gebeten lässt dann im
camp ausdrücklich erwünscht aber nur
privat sachen rtl interner zu verraten
das wird ebenfalls mit 3 zigtausend
schleifen bestraft bei schwerwiegenden
vertragsverletzungen kann es übrigens
auch sofort zum rausschmiss aus dem
dschungel kommen zum beispiel wer drogen
nimmt eine straftat begeht sich ethisch
nicht richtig verhält oder auch ohne
einwilligung mit anderen
pressevertretern sprich ups das ziel der
tunnel sternchen klar 100.000 euro
einsacken und raus aus dem dschungel
doch wer nicht aufpasst er verliert auf
dem steinigen und holprigen weg
vielleicht das ein oder andere steinchen
ohne es überhaupt schon sicher in der
tasche zu haben und dann ist der kohle
bedingte auftritt in den nächsten crash
war die sicher
[Musik]
ja wenn man nicht aufpasst dann ist die
gage möglicherweise schon durch diverse
regel stöße weg je nachdem was man dann
am ende am gage bekommt sarah hast du
schon mal gegen eine regel verstoßen und
defizite war ich meine das haben
millionen menschen gesehen ich bin aus
dem dschungel freiwillig raus gegangen
und wer daraus geht er verzichte ich auf
seine gage
das wird mir immer so unterlegt so nach
dem motto ja die hat aufgegeben da aber
ich hatte eigentlich
ja die dicksten eier sache darf man ja
bild sagen die dicksten eier weil die
anderen hätten nicht den mumm gehabt da
rauszugehen ja mich erpresst haben
gesagt ja wir gehen raus wenn wenn wenn
sie nicht raus geht ja und in
letztendlich habe ich lang gerockt
umgebracht hat ist zu verzichten ich
habe in meinem portemonnaie geguckt dass
es aus zwiebel leder und immer wenn ich
dann da reingeguckt habe sind mir die
tränen gekommen nein alles gut ich werde
darüber nicht reden weil auch ich gerne
rtl gegenüber also da auch vertraglich
verschwiegen sein möchte das bleibt mein
schmutziges geheimnis denn klose gesagt
aber ich bin rausgegangen und in dem
moment wo das damals auch mit dem
mobbing passiert ist bei mir geld auch
ehrlich gesagt egal mir bewusst wenn ich
geld kriegt kein geld so also verzicht
auf die gage und das war mir aber egal
weil meine würde mir wichtiger war und
du hast mir gerade von verraten was habe
unterredung losging dass du auch schon
mal was anders ist weil jemand beleidigt
und nähe hier kommt alles raus ja
tatsächlich hatte ich auch mal eine
schmerzliche erfahrung gemacht und zwar
habe ich auch aus dem flachs heraus
jemanden mal blöde kuh genannt na da
habe ich irgendwie laut gedacht und
diese person hat mich belogen es wurde
gefilmt und es war auch alles erkennen
dass sie gelogen hat und der spaß hat
mich tatsächlich 1000 euro gekostet und
das war zu den anfängen der karriere
eine menge geld für mich also ist auch
immer noch viel geld aber das war
schmerzlich auch für mich und da habe
ich schnell gelernt ok
lieber keine beleidigung das kriegt man
auch anders hin lass uns noch mal über
eine andere frau reden jetzt haben sie
so lange auch über janina josefi
angesprochen heute
tabitha ich kann es schon gar nicht
aussprechen sonst
hat avatar oder bieter wie auch mancher
kindermann ist aus der sauna echter name
oder ist es ich glaube das ist echter
name also ich verstehe es nicht aber wir
wissen es janina es gibt ja viele münzen
na ja einige auf ihren händen genau
liegt die dame ist ja sehr von sich
selbst überzeugt flirtet ja schon mal
ganz so lautete ja schon die ganze zeit
ordentlich mit viele pavlovic ich habe
auch gelernt er heißt nicht philipp
sondern er heißt philippe schreibe ja
ich habe oft ich hab immer verrückt
gesagt er ist verliebt und die hat eine
gar eine kleine beichte von sich gegeben
im camp und hat darüber geraten dass sie
einen only fans account hat jetzt kommt
er immer jung mag ihn liebe zuschauer
und dir liebe sarah für viel
interessanter ist eigentlich was sie vor
der kamera nicht erzählt hat schauen sie
mal
cash tv sternchen terra tabitha hält den
dschungel mit ihren pikanten geschichten
bei laune auf ihrer britsche flötete die
österreicherinnen am sonntag mit mobile
pavlovic und erzählte ihm von ihrer uni
fans karriere hat er sogar mal ein
gesetz kommt
sie haben auch high heels für 200 euro
und getragene socken 50 euro verkauft
aber sind das etwa füße oder das oder
sehen so füße aus
von wegen denn die dschungel kandidaten
hat ihren flotter nur die halbe wahrheit
verraten denn ja den fuß account gibt es
aber auch ein nackig profil und auf
diesem zweiten account geht's heiß zur
sache dort wird sie mit sexy dessous für
ihre fotos und videos und räkelt sich in
weißer spitze ihr look platin blonde
haare ihr gesicht stark geschminkt und
den körper glänzend in szene gesetzt
während laut oni fans 54 beiträge auf
terrace fuß account veröffentlicht
wurden hat der nackt account 350 fotos
und mehr als 100 videos für 20 dollar im
monat gibt es die erotischen aufnahmen
der dschungelcamp ohren zu sehen oder
gleich im drei monats abo für 54 dollar
und das alles nur weil die so schöne
füße habt
[Musik]
hat die tara ist nicht ganz genau
genommen mit der wahrheit aber das war
intelligent weil sie hat eine sehr sehr
gute werbung jetzt für ihren account
gehabt so er will muss noch mal was
anderes sprechen würdest du deine deine
socken für 50 euro deine getragen hast
du deine 10 50 euro ich würde meine
zähne für 20.000 euro verkauft
schätzen wir bieten unsere c legeland
für 100000 euro wenn svendsen käufer
gibt ich schnappe mir hierbei bild noch
ein zehner gehabt haben sie das gehört
lich wird zu wollen aber nie weil ich
neugierig wollen die lage von sarah kann
die stücke haben morgen anfangen auch
richtig mache eine option haben 100.000
die würde ich auch spenden tatsächlich
also ich würde mir ins stück zehnagel
abschneiden wenn das einer macht würde
ich das wirklich auch spenden für ein
herz für kinder 100000 euro von 18 die
auktion läuft jetzt mal gucken wie weit
wir dennoch habe ich das gemacht
was andere dazu geben oder sondern um
gottes willen ich glaube wenn ich oben
lief bei only fans machen würde oder so
ein account machen würde müsste ich den
leuten oder schmerzensgeld betroffen
waren wir menschlichen zustand nein spaß
beiseite
dieses jahr so ein phänomen das ist eben
verdient viel geld mit im vergleich also
aus verschiedenen ecken es ist ein labor
für dich ja absolut als mama ist das
gerade nicht so mein weg der nicht gehen
möchte aber ich verurteile das jetzt
auch nicht jeder soll machen dürfen
wurfbox ich meine da tut man ja auch
kein baby wird ja bestimmt in einen oder
anderen herren oder frau glücklich
machen damit
ja also ich bin mal gespannt ich bin
jetzt vor allen dingen gespannt ob ich
100000 euro mein zehnagel von
sarah ob sarah knappik ihr szenario für
100000 euro bei bild live im fernsehen
verfolgt auch mitgebracht werden wir
morgen sehen denn morgen ist sarah
wieder bei mir im buschfunk da freue ich
mich schon sehr drauf und morgen dann
nicht
eine frage und stärke das ist ich
unterbreche aber muss fairerweise damit
ich mich jetzt nicht so ganz schlecht
fühle und zu hause wieder gleich einen
auf den deckel bekommen können wir uns
darauf einigen dass du einen socken noch
von dir mit daran sich sind in die sache
kommen sollten sorten ist jetzt also
zehn tage ich habe wirklich schöne füße
also sag mal ein suche nicht erklären
wowereit einen socken dazu zu geben ich
bin mir nicht sicher ob irgendjemand
geld für meine getragenen socken
bezahlen würde ich schreibe aber auch
das können wir dann morgen herausfinden
sache es morgen wieder bei mir freue
mich schon sehr darauf er wird morgen
hoffentlich noch ein bisschen lustiger
als heute und ich schaue jetzt ganz
lustig zum schluss damit sage ich
tschüss für heute morgen geht es weiter
und denken sie daran sie können bieten
auf den 10 von sarah knapp und die
sorgen zurück und auch meine socken und
damit zurück ins studio zu sandra und
thomas